so the world's looking pretty good North
Korea's calming down no Isis
unemployment at its lowest in ages Trump
had a great meeting with that Nigerian
guy I think he wrote me a long email
once a son of 10 grant never heard from
him again
wonder what happened so while the world
seems to improve the media keeps
focusing on the worst the New York Times
get this they ran an article this week
titled happy 200th birthday Karl Marx
you were right too bad he can't read it
he's dead but what a strange thing to
say I guess the tribute to John Wilkes
Booth wasn't ready yet and where is the
Lizzie Borden centerfold but as the
writer glorifies the dead commie we here
don't believe the times went far enough
so we created a real salute happy
birthday Karl Marx you co-wrote the
communist manifesto which is right up
there with the Unabomber for the best
manifesto of all time it's basic tenant
that capitalism leads to class
oppression and will eventually be
superseded by a socialist order sweet in
fact it was such an awesome idea that a
bunch of countries tried it like Lenin
Soviet Union
featuring mass imprisonment Mao Zedong's
China with widespread famine Castro's
Cuba featuring animal powered farm
equipment in
Venezuela toilet-papered lines for J's
plus a bunch of other countries that
don't exist anymore
like East Germany Yugoslavia and
Czechoslovakia talk about a most exit
run and there's even communist nations
still around today like North Korea but
they won't admit it because it's so
successful they don't want to rub it in
the rest of the world's faces so here's
to you Karl Marx happy 200th birthday
bro
we just whip that together so as the
world enters an optimistic age the media
still chases words and not deeds the
latest freakout what Trump said about
what Giuliani said about you guessed it
stormy it was staggering we keep saying
that and it's very confusing I've never
seen anything like it
it is astonishing I think this is just
graceful it's astonishing it's stunning
just that was a disaster
other members of the legal team are and
this is not actually a legal term
freaking out
what's wrong with these people you know
what they're like they're like kids who
ate all of their Halloween candy in one
night
they're just overloaded they're gonna
end up with a DTO which is a Donald
Trump overdose but they can't stop CNN
skin and has had Stormies lawyer on 60
times in three months he gets more
airtime than pollen I think it probably
will be hard to prove Anderson you get a
stopped interrupting me the cover-up is
Willie so calm whoever the attorney is
that wrote those two tweets is an
absolute [ __ ] there's no doubt that
he's going to flip you can try to put
lipstick on the pig morning noon and
night and it's still going to be a pig
Don I was stunned I was speechless I'm
still stunned this morning every day
he's speechless which is weird because
he never shuts up that was that possible
but fair play to him he's got CNN in his
back pocket and he won't stop farting I
thought about taking that out now
remember
now remember when it was all about
collusion but now even MSNBC has doubts
this is great as for the molar
investigation I am very as an American
as a citizen I'm fascinated to know what
he finds I'm not I'm not so sure that
he's gonna find it The Smoking Gun of
coordination or collusion oh my god
MSNBC not sure about collusion
that's like Michael Moore not sure about
pie he likes pie can't change his mind
on pie so it's stormy this and stormy
that from people who used to say who
cares it's only sex the lesson if you
lose an election why not sue afterwards
it's the political equivalent of Tonya
Harding taking out Nancy Kerrigan and
the media and the Dems are Jeff Gillooly
and Shaun Eckhart the Dems push the
message the media spreads it and their
collusion broadens it's a
self-perpetuating echo chamber and the
echo is impeach because there are no
democratic ideas to counter Trump's
successes I mean how do the Democrats
top ending the North Korean nuclear
threat what would be their issues free
healthcare for ms-13
[Laughter]
horses should be able to marry sheep I'm
for that actually love is love all right
and so in a sprint shrunk made the world
better for seven point six billion
people and the question plaguing the
media's brain did a rich billionaire
playboy lie about sex I think I can save
them a year of programming time and say
yes
next next question next does America
care no see you can look at this latest
stormy stuff two different ways one is a
lawyer
Trump's allowed to pay a settlement
didn't use campaign funds nothing to do
with collusion or you could look at it
as a voter you care more about peace
than pornstars deeds more than words and
Trump's racked up a bunch so far which
brings us to this choice do you want a
wholesome but a next president who never
could have crushed Isis or figured out
North Korea or have a CAD who crushes
Isis and figures out North Korea I know
what choice I made and is the choice
America made already let us welcome
tonight's guests he's smart and tough
like an encyclopedia that can kick your
ass Fox News national security
strategist Sebastian Gorga
oh yeah he puts the tairy in military
retired Green Beret Master Sergeant in
strange pants Terry Schappert her BAC is
always higher than her BMI great joke
Nestor of you reporter Kat Tim that was
mean he's not done he takes he takes
selfies with the Hubble Space Telescope
former WWE Superstar in my massive
sidekick Tyrus dr. G we covered a lot of
ground here in this monologue I want you
to what are you thinking about what
happened this week what's the endgame
here with the media and their their
attacks on Trump with stormy what do you
wear are you
first things first that little communism
is cool thing as the trial of people who
lived under communism and escaped that's
probably how we can get the Millennials
back yeah that was the foundation for
the victims of communism did a poll
recently hmm
forty-four percent of American
Millennials want to live in a socialist
country mm-hmm Wow more than what to
live in a capitalist country they she
moved in Vermont so things have to be
done that kind of video can help us with
regards to this week you have to listen
to what the president said yesterday the
NRA meeting he relishes this stuff yeah
I've worked for the guy this is his fuel
right right right
this is a 71 year old guy I'm 47 if I
had a quarter of that man's energy at 71
I'd be happy three hours of sleep a
night he doesn't he doesn't get annoyed
by this stuff it's his fuel you come at
him he's gonna come back at you even
hardest so they're gonna lose the Jake
Tapper's the Allison Coopers they're
going to lose so you you're 47
I'm six years older than you me too it's
amazing
we're old I thought you were like much
older than me oh just a bit just the BL
so you're tall I always think tall
people are older than me is that good
I'm the size of a child Jerry they've
been growing well he has more rings if
he cut him open
yes Terry would try that actually all
right Terry how is the mainstream media
media gonna handle when there's more and
more good news we're getting crushed it
is funny about the communism thinking
about that poll that makes sense because
that by the way is by design the
Communists knew okay we're not gonna
beat these guys militarily we're not
gonna we could get them with the
educators and so these guys that this
makes sense because the people that are
that are a product of this education
system they've been fed this and they
don't know any better when they get in
the real world they're gonna figure it
out quick enough and cuz reality does
that we're I'm a combat special force
guy reality does that and I love the
best thing we were talking about
backstage backstage is where we were
ease back stains you had the green room
get to the point up not in love with
your tone but we were we were saying
that it is so much fun to watch I called
Donald Trump the flashbang cannon flash
bags are the grenades we throw in yeah
to blow up light sound and just we go in
and then shoot you because you're
stunned Trump's a group Trump's a
flashbang and it's funny to watch how he
has crushed these people and they needed
to be crushed dams and Republicans media
and academics and it's it's it's being
done by a guy who is callous Vince
skinned ego-driven
and it's beautiful yeah
these flashbang put on Flashdance cat
thoughts on anything alright I'll keep
it to the topic instead of what I was
really thinking about no there has been
a lot of good news but the media what
what it does do is doesn't cover it
it just doesn't cover it because then
that would mean they would have to admit
that Donald Trump has actually done some
good things which he has but instead
they just have stormy Daniels stories on
all day long and I don't understand what
they are cuz I don't watch it you know
that there's a lot of it but what are
they talking about for so long hooked up
yeah you lied about it yeah the end yeah
there you go I just did the whole show
yeah you did yeah yeah there's no way I
don't understand they're so shocked
these are people who said during the
Clinton era that it's just sex all right
yes exactly not ten years ago yeah and
not just with you number of people
all right Cyrus Greg and with some kind
of wisdom well we're all socialists when
we're younger until we get our own money
yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I ain't sharing a damn thing it's mines
man you told no jokes in this chair why
should I have to give it up
socials when we don't we're not
unemployed on mom's couch
yeah share the wealth yeah wealth yeah
no that's so true yeah yeah well we saw
in Finland they just they just retracted
that in Finland they had that experiment
yeah you can come Hey yeah fixed-income
for everybody in the population whether
you worked or not and guess what it
didn't work yeah speaking of Finland
where did those boots come from I think
they killed a yak yeah must have been a
pretty access the problem the problem is
the flare of his pants you should see
the jacket Kerry's new you call it a
problem I call I call it excellent yeah
I hope their flares because you're
packing heat at the ankle yes